la chronique environnement comme chaque
mardi et ce soir on va parler de la
Maison de l'environnement c'est un Manil
les Amot oui la Maison de
l'environnement des sciences et du
développement durable de sa-quenttin en
huveline on oublie toujours la suite et
nous recevons la nouvelle directrice
Sandrine lefoic bonsoir vous avez pris
votre poste il y a tout juste un mois
donc c'est c'est tout récent et donc
nous allons aborder donc les les
diverses thématiques de cette maison de
l'environnement va faire court on va pas
citer tout le le nom en entier et donc
pouvez-vous nous rappeler sa date de
création je crois que c'était lié à 7
ans exactement ça à peu près à peu près
C an parce que bon il y a il y a
toujours un temps d'émergence au projet
d'ouverture mais c'est à peu près ça
voilà et c'est la casquie qui pilote
donc c'était une volonté de de la
communauté d'agloot de 50 ans en iveline
exactement donc en fait la la la
communauté d'agglomération a une avait
en fait comme objectif de travailler sur
le développement durable de présenter en
fait son son travail sa réflexion au
grand public et d'avoir aussi un lieu de
diffusion de la culture scientifique ce
qui est assez rare et de travailler sur
le domaine de l'environnement donc ce
qui a abouti à la création de la
structure et vous venez donc tout juste
d'arriver avec forcément vos projets
auparavant on va tout de même demander à
quelques cinquantinois ce qu'ils
attendent eux de cette Maison de
l'Environnement queles sont vos attentes
c'est l'une des questions que nous vous
avons posé aujourd'hui dans les rues de
an peut-être plus d'informations au
niveau de la commune parce que c'est
vrai que au jour d'aujourd'hui j'ai pas
eu trop de
d'infos sur qui s passait ça soit plus
attractif et puis plus de publicité pour
savoir ce qu'ils font exactement qu'il
fasse de temps en temps des des débats
ils en font
mais pas suffisamment pour mon goût
personnel il y a pas beaucoup ni de
publicité ni de on a l'impression que
c'est pardon excuse-moi c'est toujours
fermé on a l'impression que c'est voilà
c'est très attirant l'idée mais c'est on
a l'impression que c'est un petit peu
voilà un petit peu refermé sur soi on va
dire plus de communication bah oui il y
a de la place là pour mettre des des
grandes affiches pour pouir y aller en
mettant sujet parce que on sait pas ce
qui se passe pas ce qui se passe dans
cette maison de l'environn donc quelle
réflexion justement il y a pas
suffisamment de visibilité mais oui
alors pourtant nous on travaille
beaucoup en communication enfin bon moi
je je suis arrivé depuis un mois mais je
vois bien que mes collègues le font
ardemment mais effectivement après bon
benah il y a une une diffusion il y a
une telle offre aussi que c'est
compliqué à mon avis de d'arriver à avir
tout ce qui est fait et et c'est bien de
de se dire que bon on peut faire on peut
s'améliorer et transmettre encore un peu
plus plus d'informations et puis j'ai
les gens en tout cas venir envie de
venir tout ce qu'ils veulent c'est
savoir ce qui s'y passe peu plus de
communication on a aussi entendu plus de
débat aussi peut-être ça aussi ça semble
intéresser quelques cquantinois ex donc
ça c'est vrai que c'est un point qui est
important parce que bon voahà une maison
de l'environnement quand on s'arrête
justement à ce nom-là on a l'impression
que c'est que pour un public scolaire et
effectivement nous la la volonté bah de
de l'établissement c'est aussi d'arriver
à toucher le le le grand public et aussi
le public adulte pour faire participer à
des débats sciences société donc des
débats c'est vraiment une forme qui est
particulièrement en plus revendiquée à
l'heure actuelle sur les avec les
questions sur le développement durable
alors est-ce que justement le fait que
vous soyez à à Manille et à Moot
excentré de 50 ans en evveline est
problématique pour cette vision
justement cette visibilité alors c'est
pas c'est pas bon c'est vrai que c'est
un c'est vrai challenge après je pense
qu'on serait central ce sera la même la
même question de de communication et
c'est vrai que nous on va avoir tendance
à rayonner autour d'un périmètre en
touchant en fait aussi d'autres communes
qui ne font pas partie de la communauté
agglomération et pour nous c'est un
c'est vrai que c'est un peu une
difficulté de de toucher les communes
les plus lointaines mais on accueille
quand même de de enfin des habitants qui
viennent qui viennent de de ces de la
périphérie on va dire de la communauté
d'agglomération et notre objectif ce
serait de pouvoir faire venir encore
plus de monde d'accord alors justement
vous venez d'arriver quelles sont vos
vos premières impressions sur cette
Maison de l'Environnement et vos visions
alors je vais je vais reprendre à des
commentaires qu'on a entendu on
entendait qu'on savait pas très bien ce
qui se passait en fait donc c'est vrai
que comme c'est un établissement qui est
tout tout neuf on a parlé de la date de
création tout à l'heure bah c'est vrai
qu'on peut avoir l'impression que c'est
un c'est un établissement qui qui qui
qui aurait envie de vivre un peu plus
donc ça je pense que c'est effectivement
quelque chose qu'on pourrait développer
ensemble avec avec l'équipe et et
d'arriver à faire des actions aussi hors
les murs pour justement arriver à à un
peu travailler cette question de de
l'implantation bon qui qui a un avantage
un inconvénient et après donc par
rapport au aux visions sur dé ement
c'est vrai que moi on m'avait demandé
aussi de travailler un peu plus à
développer la culture scientifique pour
en fait élargir le champ du domaine de
l'environnement et aller vraiment à
d'autres problématiques qui soient plus
bah pluridisciplinaire d'accord vous
parliez de hors les murs ce serait
au-delà de cqu an en Yveline non les
actions va quand même plutôt les limiter
à la communauté d'agglomération mais en
les faisant sortir de la maison de
l'environnement mais c'est vrai que nous
après dans nos partenariats on va avoir
des partenariats qui peuvent être
nationaux qui qui peuvent être aussi un
peu plus un peu plus large avec nos nos
voisins d'à côté je pense à l'université
d'Orsay la communauté d'agglomération
d'à côté aussi et puis pour s'intégrer
aussi au grands projets qui a à l'heure
actuelle sur le territoire en
Île-de-France alors vous évoquez les
sciences vous avez un parcours vous-même
assez scientifique vous avez notamment
passé le concours d'attachés de
conservation également du patrimoine
avec la spécialité patrimoine
scientifique qu'est-ce que le patrimoine
scientifique et est-ce que c'est quelque
chose qu'on peut développer ici à la
Maison de l'Environnement alors le
patrimoine scientifique c'est vrai que
c'est un volet dont on parle très peu
parce que quand on parle du patrimoine
des musées et de la conservation on
pense à objets d'art en premier après en
général on pense à à objets
archéologiques déjà là on se rapproche
un peu des domaines scientifiques que
scienceces dur et puis en fait le
patrimoine scientifique et effectivement
il revait plein plein de formes alors ce
qui est le plus connu c'est le
patrimoine naturel donc on va penser à
des animaux naturalisés donc euh
collection de zoologie et puis alors
après il y a tout ce ce qu'on appelle le
patrimoine scientifique contemporain sur
lesquels à l'heure actu actuelle le le
gouvernement travaille beaucoup qui va
être ben qu'est-ce que sont que sont les
grandes boîtes noires qui ont été qui
ont évolué tout au long du 20e siècle et
qui ont révolutionné notre environnement
notre quotidien et c'est travaillé
vraiment à une meilleure compréhension
de notre environnement immédiat et le
patrimoine scientifique donc des objets
peuvent arriver à à nous à nous montrer
en fait cette évolution là et à nous
faire prendre conscience des enjeux
aussi qui sont lié à la culture
scientifique alors c'est justement parce
que vous avez ce parcours de de de
scientifique vous a invité à venir
rejoindre l'équipe de la Maison de
l'environnement car c'est une volonté de
de la communauté d'aglo de développer
justement cette culture scientifique
exactement c'est-à-dire d'intégrer
vraiment le domaine de l'environnement à
aux différents aspects en fait de la
culture scientifique de travailler aussi
sur les débats sciences société de
travailler aussi sur les
innovations valoriser aussi les enfin
les recherches du territoire à la fois
universitaire et à la fois dans le
domaine du privé pour vraiment qu'on
qu'on se rapproche vraiment de toutes
les problématiques et peut-être quitter
un petit peu le domaine un peu classique
on va dire de domaine de l'environnement
pour mettre les choses en perspective
sans pour autant l'oublier ah non non
non non c'est important c'est vraiment
un des points fondamentals il y a pour
déjà des des thématiques scientifiques
qui sont développé au sein de la maison
d'environnement pas assez bah
effectivement donc là en fait mon
objectif c'était d'arriver à les
développer un petit peu plus que ce qui
était fait actuellement d'accord comment
vont-elles être mises en œuvre est-ce
que ça va se passer dans le courant de
cette année ou plus tard non on va faire
là à l'heure actuelle on a une
programmation qui est bien calée jusqu'à
fin enfin jusqu'à juin 2013 et puis on
va faire une évolution bah très douce en
fait pour au fur et à mesure travailler
en partenariat avec les acteurs locaux
les acteurs scientifiques pour un peu
plus susciter des débats notamment faire
venir les les cquantinois d'un peu plus
loin à la Maison de l'Environnement et
travailler progressivement en fait à à
une meilleure diffusion de la culture
scientifique pour quel public donc là on
va vraiment essayer de toucher tou
toujours le public scolaire ce toujours
un public cible mais effectivement aussi
toucher plus largement bah le grand
public alors c'est vrai qu'on touche
aussi dans les débats beaucoup d'un
public de retraité et c'est toujours
jamais très facile d'arriver à toucher
les actifs parce que bon les actifs ils
ont plein de contraintes le soir et
cetera donc le but c'est d'arriver à
trouver des formats et des sujets qui
arrivent à répondre à leurs attentes et
nous qui permettent et nous d'arriver à
susciter en fait aussi des des questions
qui sont vraiment très importantes et
POS par exemple répondre à leurs
attentes bah par exemple on peut se
poser beaucoup de de de questions par
rapport à l'effet des téléphones
portable par exemple bon ben c'est de
répondre à des questions du quotidien et
mettre les choses en perspective par
rapport à la recherche à l'heure
actuelle vous parlez justement des
téléphones portables par exemple le but
de cette maison de l'environnement c'est
de prendre position aussi dans les
débats ou juste de le susciter et
d'apporter plusieurs éléments de réponse
et puis à chacun de repartir avec les
les réponses qui lui convientent alors
je vais faire une double réponse c'està
dire que effectivement sur les
téléphones portable nous il ne s'agit
pas pour nous de d'arriver à avoir des à
des enfin une position qui va être fait
fermé puisque le but c'est vraiment
d'ouvrir au sens critique et au débat
par contre effectivement dès le moment
où on a une une approche qui va être
positionnée sur le développement durable
on a obligatoirement quand même quelques
orientations donc il a un engagement en
tout cas de cette maison environnement à
positionnement sur certains sur certains
débats de société VO VO voilà mais c'est
mais c'est vraiment quand même sur des
voilà sur des des choses très
général combien de de de public
recevez-vous tout au long de l'année et
notamment parmi les scolaires alors j'ai
pas le les chiffres en tête dans le
détail mais c'est plusieurs milliers de
personnes d'accord alors quelles seront
les grandes dates à venir prochainement
pour la Maison de l'Environnement alors
pour nous bon on a une programmation qui
est régulière he que l'on peut suivre
sur le site internet mais c'est vrai que
les grands moments Phard pour nous c'est
la semaine du développement durable
c'est la semaine qui a lieu c'est la
première semaine du mois d'avril de
mémoire c'est du 5 au 8 9 avril en 2013
et après c'est la fête de la science qui
est la deè semaine du mois d'octobre
d'accord parfait merci Sandrine le FL
donc d'être venue sur sur le plateau
nouvelle directrice de cette maison de
l'environnement mais pas seulement
puisqu'on y parle aussi de science et on
l'a bien compris ce soir Valérie pour
conclure cette page environnement
quelques dates l'agenda environnement et
ben justement ce soir on parlait débat
ce soir à 20h30 à la Maison de
l'Environnement un documentaire t
scobail un film qui dénonce la présence
dans notre environnement des OGM et du
nucléaire sans test approfondis la
séance sera donc suivie d'un débat en
présence du réalisateur Jean-Paul jou et
puis la Fondation de l'Université de
Saint-Quentin en Yveline l'UVSQ organise
une conférence jeudi 29 novembre à 20h30
à l'amphithéâtre Gérard mégi en présence
du climatologue Jean jousel coloréa du
prix Nobel de la paix en 2007 alors le
réchauffement climatique où en est-on ce
sera la question de ces conférence et on
retourne à la
maison voilà on clot avec la Maison de
l'environnement pour un spectacle
vendredi prochain à 20h30 la bataille
d'alisia une bataille qui met en scène
des salariés confrontés au dépôt de bil
an de leur entreprise et de la reprise
de celle-ci sous forme de société
coopérative et participative merci
Valérie prochain point sur
l'environnement dans le 78 la semaine
prochaine aux mêmes horaires et puis
également le magazine équilibre à
retrouver sur notre antenne et puis
également sur notre site internet comme
toutes nos Archiv
wwwtvfil78.com avant d'évoquer
l'opération menée par la Mission Locale
de plaisir nous allons prendre quelques
cours de cuisine de cuisine malgache
plus précisément connaissez-vous Valérie
le Romazava je n'ai pas cette joie et B
c'est une sorte de pote c'est un plat
typique malgache découverte à présent
donc tout en saveur à cette maison de
quartier Théodore mono c'est à Guill
encour et c'est là-bas que des plats
typiques ont été préparé par les
adhérents Johanna soudri et Patrick
Jacques de disxmud pour mariejanne Aline
et Chloé la cuisine c'est une affaire de
famille ces Guillant courtoises incarn
trois générations ensemble elles se sont
inscrites à l'atelier de cuisine
malgache à la maison de quartier
Théodore mono la grand-mère la mère et
la petite fille qu'est-ce qui vous a
motivé le partager le partager c
découvrir moi j'ai jamais fait de nem
d'habitude c'est mon père qui fait les
Nemes à la maison donc et oui les
incontournables Nemes à la crêpe de blé
garni de viande fraîche et de légumes
également au programme du cours de
cuisine les traditionnels sambos plus
connu en France sous le nom de samoussa
alors les Sambo généralement on le fait
quand on reçoit du monde on le met en en
apéritif la force c'est les facile à
faire mais c'est le pliage qui prend du
temps voilà c'està dire faire le
triangle il faut un petit coup de main
ou ouais ouais qu'est-ce qui est le plus
difficile selon vous
c'est le manipuler la la pâte parce
qu'elle sèche très très vite autreet
caractéristique de Madagascar le hachar
une salade de légumes à dégusté avec le
riz quotidien c'est composé de carottes
de chou de haricot vert sans oublier les
poivrons et la vinaigrette élisette fait
partie de l'association Espoir foi et
amour qui propose régulièrement des
activités autour de la culture malgache
d'autres ateliers culinaires seront mis
en place à la maison de quartier
Théodore mono pour promouvoir les
cultures du monde et comme on dit en
malgache m tout
il n reste